do you agree with Chomsky on the his
General harsh criticism of U.S foreign
policy in war that
many actions military actions in the
United States are criminal in nature
almost terrorists in nature I very much
disagree with those who take the view
that the U.S is this
um wonderful Global police force that's
spreading democracy and fixing problems
very very much wrong
I think where I've had disagreements
with Chomsky in the past is more he
frame he seems to frame the U.S as a
uniquely bad actor in some of these
cases and I think it's more an
outcropping of the size and wealth of
the US and less about uniquely negative
intentions and so I think that would be
my general disagreement with Chomsky
based on stuff I read a decade